dan tintin tintin tintin tintin tintin
tintin welcome back to my favorite
movies this segment where I can tell you
guys about my favorite movies so far
I've hit Scott Pilgrim vs. the world and
predator today we're gonna be talking
about a film that honestly never gets
old in fact it gets better
jaws Roy Scheider Robert Shaw Richard
Dreyfuss jaws see him before you go
swimming despite the fact that Jaws was
actually Steven Spielberg's second film
that he directed that was released
theatrically this is the film where most
people feel Steven Spielberg came into
his own this film came out in 1975 and
it's also viewed as the first big
blockbuster that term was invented
because people would line up outside the
theater all the way around the block and
they'd bust the block it happened again
two years later when Star Wars came out
but jaws was the one where everyone
lined up to see this movie it was the
first movie to ever grossed more than a
hundred million dollars you guys know
the plot of this movie is there's a
killer shark that has staked a claim of
territoriality off the shores of Amity
Island it's picking off people left and
right and Roy Scheider Richard Dreyfuss
and Robert Shaw go out on a hunt to find
this thing and kill it I had the
privilege of actually seeing this film
in theaters a few years ago and it was
actually projected by the original film
reel from the 70s seeing that in the
theater was so incredible because I've
grown up with this film I remember the
first time I saw it I was a little bit
too young to appreciate it my parents
showed it to me I was probably like
maybe like six or something they were
very trusting with me as a child I liked
it as a kid I was very entertained by it
but I'll never really forget the first
time where I truly appreciated jaws for
what it was my parents used to have a
subscription to the TV Guide back when
it was just like a little booklet and it
was basically just TV listings inside
there and now it's like a legit magazine
nevertheless I was flipping through it
and I saw that Sunday at 9 p.m. I'll
never forget it was a Sunday at 9 p.m.
and I remember the reason I was so
excited about watching jaws Sunday at 9
p.m. was because my parents gave me
permission to stay up way later past my
usual bedtime because Monday was school
but they said fine you can watch jaws
but you have to go to bed
directly after Jaws I stayed up that
summer night I'll never forget it was
one of the first summer nights where the
time had changed so we were getting
longer days and I remember as jaws
started the Sun was still out it was
nice and warm outside and I was able to
watch jaws for the first time as a young
kid and truly appreciate it ever since
then it's been one of my favorite movies
it's easy to look at a film like jaws
and the height that surrounds it and how
you hear about it so many times and
forget about the fact that it's not just
about a killer shark it's not just a fun
adventure movie it actually has quite a
bit of heart to it and real characters
that are likable and feel like real
people and that's why later in the film
when certain things are happening you're
not going look at the cool sharks
swimming around you're like oh watch out
chief Brody don't get bit you know
you're caring about the characters
you're not so much excited about ol ears
the shark I mean that's cool but the
reason this film works so well was
because of those characters you cared
about them it was a well-written film
adapted from the original novel by Peter
Benchley like early on in the movie you
get lots of family scenes you see Roy
Scheider with his family you get that
great scene the table where him and his
son mock each other as they make faces
that is one of the reasons why this
movie is so special it's not just a
creature feature it has real characters
in it and they're well fleshed out and
they're funny and likable people the
late Roy Scheider playing chief Brody is
absolutely terrific in this film Richard
Dreyfuss plays this oceanographic
scientist of sorts who comes out and
helps them hunt the shark and Robert
Shaw is the insane fisherman who helps
them catch him who has lots and lots of
stories which leads to possibly the best
scene in the movie and which Steven
Spielberg has said is his favorite scene
in the film the discussion these guys
have in the boat at night when they sing
the song together when they show their
scars and then Quint talks about the
Indianapolis Sharks got lifeless eyes
dolls eyes oh then you hear that
terrible I pitch screaming they all come
in and rip you to pieces it's a scene
that has everything in it has comedy it
has drama and it has suspense all
wrapped up into one scene and that's
also another reason this movie works so
well is it's a terrific mismatch of
various genres all in the encompassing
thought of this is a creature feature
adventure
horror-thriller but it's got comedy in
there it's got drama in there it has
realistic human characters and it has a
really awesome shark that to this day
still works and that's because of Steven
Spielberg he has since said that a
deal-breaker for him in this movie was
he wasn't going to take this project
unless they gave him permission to not
show the shark for at least the first
half of the movie that is impressive and
that's one of the reasons why the movie
works so well and the shark works so
well is because he uses things like the
doc floating and the barrels to take the
place of the shark now yes a lot of the
times that was actually used because the
shark wasn't working and so they had to
improvise but he was very very careful
with not showing too much of the shark
so it didn't become obvious that it was
some sort of prosthetic you know
animatronic thing now if anyone has ever
done a review of this movie without
mentioning John Williams score you have
failed
John Williams creates one of the most
simple main themes ever that has become
one of the most effective themes for a
villain in a film Spielberg himself has
said that that film success was 50%
because of John Williams
I've watched scenes of Jaws with the
music taken out it's completely
different it's a totally different movie
John Williams improved that movie so
much as he does with every movie that he
composes for but not just the sharks
theme all the various themes that he
weaves throughout this movie and the
music that he composes especially for
this great scene where they're trying to
get the barrel connected to the rope so
they can shoot it at the shark because
they're all running out of time and the
shark is coming and who both come on
whoo butter it up tight on but he's
coming OOP aah Oprah that scene is
fantastic and the whole movie is
fantastic honestly jaws is a film that
seemed to scene to scene to scene
absolutely rivets I loved it as a kid I
loved it as an adult I watched it at
least once a year and each time I watch
it it feels like it just gets better and
better if you haven't checked out the
blu-ray the blu-ray transfer is pristine
it's one of the best transfers I've seen
for an older film it's a movie that has
terrific human characters in situations
that are larger than life and scary but
because of those human characters and
because you care about them and because
of how well-made this film was despite
the production difficulties despite all
the problems that Spielberg had to face
while making this movie jaws is a film
that continues to inspire
countless independent filmmakers and
people who would love to be a filmmaker
one day and I know it definitely has
done that to me as well
jaws for sure gets an A+ so that's
another review of one of my favorite
movies I will have more to come very
soon guys thanks as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes